Welcome, and as you join us today to explore Reza Shakazemi's spiritual ethos, we arrive at the letter's close, where the whole edifice of just rule turns out to rest on something done alone in the dead of night.
It is such a stark image to begin with, really.
Know that your every act is dependent upon your prayer.
That single line.
I mean, it completely reframes everything we have discussed in this deep dive so far.
It really does.
Because if you manage a team or run a business or even just try to keep a household from falling apart, we usually think about governance purely in terms of visible systems.
And up until now, the Imam, peace be upon him, has spent this entire letter counseling the governor
He counsels on those very intricate, highly visible mechanics of rule.
He has laid out these incredibly rigorous methods, methods for weighing the different classes of society against one another, detailed instructions for appointing judges, managing the affairs of merchants, directing the conduct of soldiers.
Those profound warnings about restraining the ruler's own appetites.
All of that forms the outward face of justice.
It's the visible architecture of placing everything in its objective order in the physical world.
But most manuals of statecraft, they stop entirely at that visible architecture.
They do because the political mind desperately wants metrics it can track.
For sure.
It wants ledgers and council chambers and observable policies, systems that can be audited by committees.
We tend to build societies on this assumption that if the external scaffolding is strong enough, the building will just, it will stand regardless of who occupies it.
But the central crisis presented here shatters that assumption completely.
It does.
The argument is that this entire visible architecture is profoundly, terrifyingly vulnerable.
Because every measured judgment, every honest appointment.
Restraint of executive power.
It all relies on an invisible foundation.
I mean, good intentions are completely insufficient here.
Clever policies are.
insufficient.
The capacity to place things rightly in the physical world must be drawn down from a higher source.
Which brings us to the ultimate stakes of this text.
What happens when the ruler is unwatched?
That is the crisis.
What sustains justice when there is no ledger recording the action and no public observing the decision?
When there is no immediate consequence for selfishness.
If justice is merely a performance for the public, it collapses the very moment the public is removed.
We see that all the time, don't we?
Leaders who are brilliant in public but become entirely different people behind closed doors.
Which introduces the first governing analogy we really need to sit with.
The text presents prayer as a fountain overflowing into every action.
A fountain.
I like that.
The inward practice is the hidden spring from which all public good flows.
So governance drawn from this spring is qualitatively different from
something just manufactured by political calculation.
Inherently different.
And to understand how this overflow functions, we have to look closely at how the ruler connects to this source.
The phrase used is purifying one's religion.
I feel like on the surface, purifying one's religion might sound to a modern ear like, well, just a simple instruction to avoid hypocrisy.
Like a basic directive to ensure public rituals aren't performed just for applause.
Just a warning against showing off.
But it reaches far deeper into the human interior than that.
To purify one's religion is to purify the very substance of the soul's relationship to God.
The text insists on this really radical premise, doesn't it?
Insists that no virtue, whether it is justice, patience, or mercy, can rise higher than the soul's nearness to the source of that virtue.
A virtue is only as real and only as durable as the relationship that feeds it.
That shifts the entire ethical framework from a horizontal
to a vertical one.
Ethics is no longer just a list of rules to memorize.
Or a social contract you can negotiate.
It becomes a measure of proximity to the divine.
Let's define this proximity because the tradition provides a highly specific concept here.
The term is takorob.
It represents cultivating a right vision in prayer.
And this cultivation is the only way right action is generated in the physical world.
Because right action does not just conjure itself out of a vacuum, nor is it sustained by willpower alone.
It flows from a right vision.
This vision is cultivated in prayer or nowhere at all.
The Quran itself states that reciting the book and establishing the prayer restrains from indecency and wrongdoing.
It places drawing near as the absolute root of all ethical restraint.
Which reveals why the obligatory prayers are so heavily emphasized in the life of a leader, they act as appointed interruptions.
Because A ruler's life, by definition, is completely consumed by the ceaseless, crushing demands of administration.
The fixed, recurring prayers force the ruler to physically leave the business of statecraft, to step away from the council chamber and stand defenseless before the one to whom they must ultimately answer.
Defenseless is the operative word there.
The posture of power is dismantled.
But, and this is vital, it is not a passive defenselessness.
The text places striking, almost alarming physical demands on this.
It really does.
The letter says, give unto God of your vital energy in your nights and your days, and perform fully that by which you draw near to God, doing so perfectly, without becoming dull or deficient, taking your body to its limits.
The physical intensity described there is severe.
I mean, this is not a request for a few minutes of quiet contemplation to lower your blood pressure before a stressful meeting.
Not at all.
It demands one's vital energy.
It speaks of taking the body to its limits.
An immense expenditure of effort across the days and the nights, even when the demands of the state are already exhausting the individual.
Which brings in the third governing analogy, driving home this theme of relentless effort.
Yes, the imam states that prayer without strenuous exertion is like arrows loosed without a bow.
That is an unforgiving image.
It forces us to confront the physics of spiritual intention.
Gesture without tension cannot hit the mark.
Because motion without the instrument that gives it force achieves absolutely nothing.
An arrow thrown by hand simply falls to the ground.
Sincerity demands the undivided integration of the soul.
Gathering all those scattered energies, all the anxieties and divided attentions of a ruling mind into a single piercing orientation that takes immense labor.
A fragmented soul cannot offer a sincere prayer because sincerity is defined here as the undividedness of the one who prays.
I want to build on that physics analogy for a second.
We are essentially talking about the difference between moving heavy weights in a gym and just pantomiming the motion in the air.
If you just go through the motions of a bicep curl,
Without holding any weight, your muscle never tears, it never rebuilds, it never actually strengthens.
The resistance is what creates the transformation.
But this raises a critical question about the outcome of all this labor.
If the ruler takes their body to its limits, drawing the bow with everything they have, sweating through this internal resistance,
What is the resulting transformation?
What actually happens to the practitioner?
Yes.
To answer that, the text introduces the teaching of the Prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
The text points to a luminous, highly celebrated saying often referred to as the Hadith of drawing near.
In this saying, God speaks in the first person.
The structure of that saying is mesmerizing.
It fundamentally distinguishes between two types of devotion.
First, God declares that the slave draws near through nothing.
He loves more than a
obligatory acts.
So the obligatory acts, the required foundational duties, they establish the baseline relationship.
But then the saying moves further into uncharted territory.
It states that the slave never ceases to draw near through supererogatory acts until God loves him.
For anyone listening who might be unfamiliar with the term, supererogatory acts are those freely offered devotions undertaken entirely beyond all basic requirements.
They are.
It is the spiritual equivalent of staying hours after your shift ends.
just to help a colleague simply out of love for the work rather than just showing up to fulfill a contract.
The freely offered devotion deepens the relationship into intense intimacy.
And then comes the astonishing claim at the heart of the saying, God says, and when I love him, I am his hearing by which he hears, his sight by which he sees, his hand by which he grasps, and his foot by which he walks.
I have to push back here.
I mean, that sounds like wordplay.
Isn't God becomes his hand just a fancy way of saying he acts well?
You think it's just a metaphor?
It feels like a battiful, metaphorical flourish to describe someone who has developed really solid moral habits.
We use language like this all the time to describe someone who is simply very focused, you know?
I understand the instinct to reduce it to metaphor.
The modern mind wants to domesticate language like this to make it merely symbolic so it fits neatly into our material
realist worldview.
It is more comfortable that way.
But the text does not permit that reduction.
It demands we read this as a profound ontological reality.
An actual shift in being.
The ego is literally a face through the physical and spiritual act of prostration.
When the text commands the self to bow down, it is describing a self-effacement that creates a vacuum.
A vacuum that allows the divine presence to become the very faculty of perception.
The text means exactly what it says.
His hearing by which he hears.
His sight.
We are talking about a fundamental alteration in how a human being perceives reality then.
It's not just about choosing to do good things.
It is about the optical lens through which the world is viewed being completely swapped out.
I see.
To see things as they truly are rather than through the distorted funhouse mirror of one's own ego, insecurities and appetites is the absolute prerequisite for justice.
Think about how a selfish leader views a forest.
They just see lumber and profit.
And A terrified leader sees a place for enemies to hide.
Only a leader whose perception has been clarified can see the forest for what it actually is in the grand order of creation.
If you cannot see a thing as it truly is, you cannot possibly place it where it truly belongs.
And placing each thing according to what it truly is defines perfect justice.
That completely changes the center of gravity of a whole life.
The rigid boundaries we usually draw between private devotion and public work just dissolve here.
We usually think of a leader's schedule as a zero-sum game.
An hour spent in prayer is an hour stolen from managing the economy or listening to the grievances of the citizens.
The logic of the overflow makes that zero-sum thinking obsolete.
How so?
If a ruler gives God the most excellent, undivided portion of their time, they do not have less capacity for the people.
They actually have infinitely more.
They bring the gathered quality of nearness, that clarified perception, directly to their subjects.
So the private practice and the public good
are not competing for a fixed number of hours on a schedule.
The hidden spring feeds the public action.
A ruler who spends the night gathering their soul into unity will not spend the day tearing the state into factions.
Having established that the overflow of nearness transforms perception itself, we really need to examine the mechanics of this transformation.
We do.
Nearness sustained amidst the chaos of governing?
What keeps the perception clear when 1,000 different crisis points are screaming for the ruler's attention?
Know that your every act is dependent upon your prayer.
We are shifting to the specific method of maintaining that clarity.
The text introduces the specific supererogatory devotion at the heart of this nearness.
The text uses the term Dipkar.
It functions as both a methodic practice
the deliberate, rhythmic, repeated invocation of divine names, and a permanent condition of awareness.
It is the concentrated act performed in isolation and the abiding condition carried into the crowded marketplace simultaneously.
It is the striking of the match in the dark room and the residual warmth that fills the room long after the initial friction.
Which leads us to the second governing analogy of the text.
The text compares the human heart to a mirror or a blade.
Through the friction of daily life,
Through the accumulation of minor compromises, distractions, and neglect, this mirror becomes dulled and clouded with oxidation.
Remembrance is the polish.
It is the friction applied to burnish the heart until it recovers senses it had lost.
Through this polishing, the heart achieves hearing after deafness and seeing after blindness.
There is a crucial distinction to draw out regarding how this polish works.
Remembrance is not the acquisition of new information.
That is such a vital point.
The entire modern educational paradigm is based on forward accumulation.
We assume learning means moving forward, downloading facts we did not possess yesterday.
Adding new tools to our mental toolbox.
The text describes remembrance operating uniquely with time.
It moves downward and backward.
It is fundamentally an act of recovery.
Think of it like running a defragmentation or a factory reset on a heavily corrupted computer.
You are not installing new software to fix the glitches.
You are stripping away all the accumulated malware, all the junk files, all the fragmented data that have bogged down the system over the years.
In order to uncover the pristine operating system that was there from the moment the machine was built.
It uncovers what was forgotten.
a new reflective surface onto the metal blade.
It strips away the grime that has obscured the mirror-like quality the metal always possessed.
The faculties of hearing and sight are returned after lapsing.
They are not gifted as brand new senses.
This means the busiest governor commanding armies and the most secluded contemplative meditating in a cave are digging in the exact same ground.
Their own solitary hearts.
They're both trying to strike the same inherent bedrock.
And the text brings in the wisdom of the early Sufi master to address the sheer psychological difficulty of this digging.
Because the mind rebels against this kind of repetitive polishing.
It does.
The early Sufi master counsels the practitioner not to abandon the practice simply because they fail to be present within it.
He warns profoundly that heedlessness of the practice is far worse than heedlessness within it.
Returning to the archery analogy, the marksman keeps drawing the bow until the aim comes true.
If you are distracted while
drawing the bow, you will miss the target.
But if you put the bow down entirely because you are frustrated with missing, you lose the muscle memory.
The calluses on your fingers soften.
And you cease to be an archer altogether.
The sustained effort held through its own glaring imperfection is the very workshop where sincerity is eventually forged.
The integration of the soul happens in the struggle itself.
The friction of failing to focus and choosing to return to the invocation anyway is what strips the rust from the mirror.
But we have to address how this internal, solitary labor connects back to the external world.
How does digging in the ground of one's own solitary heart translate to governing a complex, chaotic society?
That is the ultimate test of the text's thesis.
Because if this doesn't translate to the physical world, it remains just a beautiful theory for hermits.
The text lays out the hinge of the entire argument here.
It describes those who truly belong to the remembrance.
It states that these individuals are steadfast in justice and critically they are able to instruct others in it.
Putting the highest thing, first placing God at the absolute center through continuous remembrance
equips a person to place everything else in the material world in its proper proportional order.
I don't buy that yet, honestly.
I mean, how can private prayer be the source of public justice?
Doesn't fervent inward spirituality come at the expense of effective action in the real world?
You feel they are fundamentally opposed.
The contemplative life and the administrative life seem to pull in entirely opposite directions.
One requires deep withdrawal and silence, while the other requires constant engagement, endless talking, pragmatic compromise.
It is a common concern.
History is full of deeply spiritual people who were terrible administrators because they couldn't handle the harsh realities of the physical world.
The text actually anticipates that exact modern suspicion.
It completely refutes the idea that spirituality and practical action are rivals by introducing the classical Ismaili reading.
Guided by the Aga Khan, the tradition insists that faith and world are not competing claims fighting over a finite pie of human attention.
They are.
a single, undivided fabric.
The believer does not withdraw from the world permanently to be near God.
The believer draws near to God in the depth of the night in order to return to the world at dawn, carrying what the world alone could never give.
I see what you mean now.
I really concede that point.
If justice is merely a set of external rules applied by a skilled technician, then that technician will inevitably bend the rules the moment self-interest makes bending attractive.
A technician of the law has no internal anchor against the immense gravity of power.
They know how the law works, but their ego still controls their application of it.
But if justice is understood as a radiance of the real and the leader's perception has been altered so they actually see the real, then inward rectitude genuinely prevents outward corruption.
The steadfastness in justice out in the streets
and the steadfastness in practice alone in the room are the exact same discipline seen from two different sides.
Justice is at once the cause and the consequence of worship.
The outward justice is the undeniable overflow of inward rectitude.
Take away the nearness to the real, take away the polishing of the mirror, and you are left with nothing but a competent mimicry of justice.
And mimicry always shatters under enough political or financial pressure.
This integration of inner devotion and outward order completes a philosophical puzzle
that one of history's greatest minds left unfinished.
The scope of this argument is expanding.
It is.
We must steel man Plato's The Republic.
We must present his argument at its absolute strongest to understand the magnitude of what the imam provides.
Socrates constructs a massive, rigorous educational apparatus designed to lead the philosopher guardian to the sovereign good.
The sovereign good is the highest object of knowledge from which everything right and beautiful derives its value.
Socrates outlines A grueling decades-long
ascent for the mind.
Arithmetic to break the reliance on the physical senses.
Geometry, solid geometry, astronomy, harmonics.
And finally, the ultimate discipline of dialectic.
It is a lifelong program of intense intellectual purification.
The guardians are meant to slowly lift the eye of the soul, turning it away from the shadows on the cave wall, to eventually gaze on that which sheds light on all things.
Once they see the good itself, they return to the cave and take that ultimate vision as a pattern for the right ordering of the state.
But the text exposes the glaring omission in this magnificent system.
After building this entire apparatus, after mapping the cosmos and the human mind,
Socrates is pressed by Glaucon to actually describe the good.
Glaucon asks for a direct account of it.
And Socrates declines.
He confesses, it is beyond my powers.
Describes the ascent meticulously.
He notes beautifully that knowledge is recollection.
But he leaves the passage dark regarding how to actually gaze upon the light when you reach the summit.
He never names the specific inward practice required to know the source of the forms, known in this context as the fashioner.
Wait, couldn't Plato's mention in his 7th letter a long partnership in a common life?
Just
practical philosophical education, not a missing spiritual method.
You mean it might just be rigorous study?
It doesn't necessarily mean there is a mystical void in his system.
It could just be the rigorous dialectic process itself, requiring immense time and conversation between students and teachers.
Plato's own words in his 7th letter suggest otherwise.
He explicitly denies that the true reality of philosophy can be set out in any written exposition or verbal argument.
Oh, I see.
He states that after this long partnership and deep devotion, the truth flashes like a flame kindled by a leaping spark in the soul.
A flame kindled by a leaping spark is not the language of a math equation finally solved
through rigorous debate.
It is the language of sudden transcendent illumination that occurs beyond logic.
Plato deeply senses the reality of this illumination, but leaves it entirely unmethodical.
He gestures towards something he will not or cannot specify.
He brings the soul to the very threshold of the door, but does not provide the key to open it.
He tells you the door exists.
He tells you why you must go through it to be a just ruler.
but he leaves you standing in the hallway.
The text contrasts the submission by placing 2 historical scenes side by side.
We have Glaucon pressing Socrates, resulting in Socrates demurring, stepping back from the ultimate description.
Then we have the questioner who pressed the imam.
The man asks with incredible directness, how did you see him?
And the imam does not demur.
He does not claim it is beyond his powers.
He gives a direct experiential account of real seeing.
He says, hearts
see him through the verities of faith.
The imam climbed the summit that Sovrates only pointed toward.
More importantly, the imam provides the specific devotional method remembrance, the arduous polishing of the heart in the dead of night that sublimates and fulfills Plato's political philosophy.
The phrasopher mapped the mountain from a distance.
The imam provides the physical path up the rock face, hammering the pitons into the stone so others can actually make the climb.
The arc of the text's argument reaches its completion here.
Justice is sacred because
It is rooted in the real.
It cannot be manufactured by policy alone, no matter how clever or heavily enforced the policy is.
It must be assimilated into the very biology of the leader through the drawing near that effaces the ego and polishes the heart.
This inward transformation alone allows justice to overflow naturally into the world, like water from an endless spring.
Know that your every act is dependent upon your prayer.
We have spent this time examining the outward fruit of justice.
looking at how leaders structure societies and make decisions.
But the text demands we look at the root of the tree, and the root is always underground, hidden in darkness.
Think about your own life, in those quiet, unwatched hours in the dead of night when nobody's asking anything of you.
When you attempt to polish the mirror of your own intellect, when you sit alone with your own thoughts, what reality are you actually allowing to speak through you?
Are you putting in the exhausting labor to recover the immutable principles always inscribed within your soul, or are you just rearranging the world's shadows?